so Ellie very excited to be here at
collector mania and great to see your on
game returns as well how is it being one
of the new girls it's absolutely amazing
being one of the new girls I'm so
excited to be part of the gang it's
great and you've got a lovely going on
gamers groans haven't you you've got me
with brand Isaac Hampstead right you're
with Hodor as well Christian er Natalia
tena how are these guys to work with
they were all a lot of fun to her that
she because we were sort of yet we
formed like a little splinter group off
from the main kind of cast because you
know sort of trekking around the woods
and like you can you can only stay sane
if you're doing that with like nice fun
people and they're great like we had a
lot of fun out there it was yet there
are fantastic log gang we were got on
really well I heard that from Christian
that he had a little pouch healed a
little belt and he's carrying around
everyone's iPhones and that yeah yeah I
wouldn't be surprised he had so much
stuff in there he had such a hard time
because he has like this massive costume
it which is like incredibly heavy
because we film those and stuff outside
often it gets like really really wet and
really muddy so by the end of the day
he's like kind of slumping around being
like oh my god and carrying around like
10 extra pounds so that yeah but he's no
he's great he's a really he's a really
fun and you actually had a friend on the
show before you came on didn't you oh
yes I did yeah I went to university with
Hannah Murray who plays Gilly and I got
a cast in the show and we found out that
we had a scene together which is just
amazing considering how many characters
there are in Game of Thrones right so
yeah we had this scene together which is
a lot of fun where we both being a bit
silly but was great and yeah it was
really nice because we were filming at
the same time at Belfast together so I
hang out with her a lot
have you found filming in Belfast I've
loved love filming in Belfast actually
because I'd never been to Northern
Ireland before and it's a mate like the
city is obviously amazing and it has so
much kind of history it's a really
important place but I and I hadn't
realised that out stray outside of
Belfast is like the most amazing
countryside which you see in the show
obviously you know like really really
beautiful landscapes it was just like
fantastic that it was like oh this is
our job to go out here and watch the
sunset over like this coast of Northern
Ireland
you know we're fantastic yeah okay she's
quite a feisty character isn't she old
mirror Oh young we're even now one of
the things we've seen you do this season
is skinning rabbits tell me what that
was like actually on set ah well yes I'm
now very good at it because it's
certainly a skill that I've taken away
from the job but um yeah that we had to
sadly we had to get through a lot of
rabbits because they filmed so many
camera angles the show so you can take
like a day to do a whole day to do a
scene which is what we did with the
rabbits Kinney scene and then we tell
you the smell of rabbits you cannot get
out of your hands throughout two days
and we were like when we when we had to
eat lunch we like me and NAT were like
oh god I kind of got a thing smells do
bad but you know at least we have the
skill of being able to skin them but it
was kind of like that was that was a
test that was the most testing part of
it but actually it was the most
rewarding day because there's a really
fun scene to do despite rabbit corpses
so yeah it was it was nice just way old
ugly see if you ever find yourself in
like a Hunger Games scenario something
you go don't you yeah exactly rabbit
stew I'm your lady so
and tell me about the costumes as well
that you were on the show
the questions are amazing actually and
Michelle Clapton is the question
designer and she's incredibly talented
and and I've worked with her on another
thing before in the Diary of Anne Frank
a few years ago and she's like really
really detailed and everything that she
does so like my costume consisted of
like because we eat rabbits in the show
I had like rabbit fur a real rabbit fur
over my shoulders and like this
beautiful kind of fabric as a sort of
cape and this like this like laser cut
leather from Italy like as partly like
as probably like kind of a moss and a
hair and like a shirt with like real
hair in it like the whole thing there
was incredibly detailed and like loads
of like leather and a little mossy
trousers and it was one I think it was
definitely my favorite costume I've ever
got to wear because it's just yeah it
was so much fun and I loved being a girl
and Game of Thrones he wears trousers so
a real tomboy is this year yeah I think
she's a bit like me in that in that
respect that I'm I've never been like
much of a girly girl and so that's why
as soon as I read a script I was like
yes I really want this part because
she's so much fun she's so badass I love
that about her I like her attitude as
well because she's when Otto says to her
about all you know he can't protect
himself and you say something like um
you know a man that yeah yeah we're the
same and that just means with someone
can't look after sods I don't need
deserve looking after yeah exactly like
this is the thing like something I
really like about her as a character
it's that she's really really feisty but
at the same time she's an incredibly
caring character and like she just
really loves a Rolla Jojen
she's totally there for him and they're
very cool they're like he's totally cool
with the fact that like his older sister
who's a girl is protecting him and she
doesn't care that like you know that
like that he needs protecting she's
totally up for it so yeah it's great
they're really cute pair I reckon
whatever kind of a mystery a little bit
at the moment still is it we're learning
a little bit more as each week passes
walking's coma
than Jo Jones kind of teaching bran
what's going on ahsha's not at all
impressed issue yeah OSHA is not down
with other all of that walking she
really doesn't like it does she know um
yeah they you can only wait to just
sleep that's good just can be a lot more
exciting yet talent
skills which will be revealed to brand
through jjan who is like a mastermind
he's just kind of it they call him I
think in the books he's called little
grandfather because he's like really
wise beyond his years and that is
totally what Thomas Sangster is he's
like he really enjoys like cigars and
like motorbikes and he's like he's so
lovely but he's very much he's very
grown-up it's great Dimity great working
with those guys that yeah it was so much
fun working with them and not yet as I
said before I was really lucky to be
working with like because it was such a
tight-knit group to be working with a
really like nice group of people like
really good people so it's good now you
said you're a bit of a tomboy yourself
bit like mirror so how do you think
you'd make out if you were plunked in
the middle of her world and Game of
Thrones well I know now that I would be
able to skin a rabbit if I needed to and
I reckon you know I reckon I'd probably
uncover like an unsettlingly vicious
side to my character but I've started to
learn how to shoot with a bow and arrow
thanks for the show so you know might be
able to hold my own I'm liking it I'm
liking it now obviously we're so pleased
that it could never been in question
obviously a season four but it has been
confirmed now where would you like to
see Mira going in season four and what
would you I mean anything from the books
you'd love to actually see in season
four well I mean I can't confirm
anything yet because whilst the series
is going ahead I'm not you know I'm not
completely sure what's happening but I'd
love it if if Mira's storyline which
happens in the books where spoiler alert
if anyone hasn't read the books she goes
into this mad cave with like children of
the forest and like it's incredible and
if that makes its way into the series
and absolutely love its that sounds
wicked but we'll have the way to see is
there anything you'd like to see
happening to the other characters in the
show as well not necessarily ones in
your storyline but anybody else you've
been reading about yeah well I mean my
favorite character is probably Arya so I
just I'm really looking forward to
seeing how her character develops in the
next series and if it's the same as the
books if it's not well suppose we have
to wait and see yeah difficulty how do
you think I and Maria get on
I reckon they get on pretty well
actually because in the books brand says
that the reason why he likes Mira is
because she reminds him of his sister so
I reckon we'd get on like that may be a
bit too similar though you know I met
Maisie Williams in real life obviously
he plays them who plays aya and she's
she's brilliant she's really really cool
so yeah so I get on with that real life
but I may know about don't I'm up in the
fictional world what if even your
favorite scenes and moments you enjoyed
in acting on the small screens over I
think games Laurent has to be like one
of my favorite like characters I play
just because it takes you to mind places
like in the middle of the forest by a
campfire like sharpening in an arrow
blade or something and things that I
never would've thought I'd be doing and
that's been amazing and very different
to like kind of some of the other work
I've done so like I guess the other
biggest thing that I did was I did a
five-part series of diagram Frank right
which was in a tiny studio which is like
completely reconstructed exactly to the
dimensions and everything of the actual
annex which I wasn't hiding in so I've
done if it was like that works we're all
like cramped up into this tiny space and
then to go on to Game of Thrones where
it's massive and so expansive it was
great to be able to have like the chance
to do loads of yeah closed off in
different locations and they've done a
lot of stage work too and you were in
very moon Juliet weren't you and I read
that you did a lot of breathing
exercises kind of get into them to that
role as well and I was wondering if
there was anything particularly you did
to get into the role of mirror for Game
of Thrones um what does it again to into
the role of mirror I am I sort of like
they went out like like on a quiet love
walks into the woods before I got and
was like how would I had I behave I was
me right now but I always had to do it
on my own because I didn't want any of
my friends to see me because that would
be much too embarrassing luckily there's
a love words around where my parents
live and that was good but when I
actually got there I guess I did a lot
of well a little bit of training in
archery which is great because it's just
really nice to be able to know how to
use
and how to look when I'm holding it and
we had several days of prepping for the
rabbits getting scenes like there was
this butcher who came in to like teach
us how to do it for like three days the
first the first job I had to do on Game
of Thrones was like yet you're coming
for two days of rabbit prepping before
you start shooting so yeah yeah and how
would you rate yourself as an archer oh
well I couldn't possibly say I've got a
lot to learn there's an amazing guy out
in Belfast and who when you're filming
if you want to learn how to do archery
you can just are asked to book a lesson
with him so I booked a few but I didn't
have enough time in my schedule to book
as many as I'd like so I really want to
get good if I'm back next year then I'd
love to do more and get like become a
pro you know shoot people down not
people obviously maybe rabbits another
there Joffrey coming in there yeah yeah
you didn't see that and what it would
have been you're kind of oh my god I
can't believe they've done it on this
show moment so far from the first second
or third theory I think the maddest
thing this is a small thing but just the
maddest thing was having a whole deer
carcass you know that you seen with
Charles ants when he has to skin that
whole deer carcass and like they
actually had a real deer on set and if
you think about it with like all of the
lights and the crew and everyone
shooting that scene for a long time that
was like yeah pretty impressive I mean
you've got to be very dedicated to your
job to do that so that weirdly even
though it was a tiny moment that was the
moment I was like wow these guys really
care make you feel glad that you only
had to do rabbits oh yeah I got off easy
like a person clearly of course there's
been some striking deaths on the show as
well and obviously we don't want you to
be using your head or anything else
anytime soon when you just got to know
you this season but if you had to go how
would you like to go oh wow what a
question if I had to go I think it would
have to be in like a screaming like ax
fight with
Osia because she's just nuts Anna is a
lot of fun to work with and she's
completely mad and I reckon that OSHA
can have a very violent side which would
come out so I think that'll be a fun way
to die and is there anyone you'd like to
find at the other end of that arrow oh
oh I couldn't possibly say no no no no I
think really you know like mirror
ultimately pretty peaceful character I
think only only rabbits and little tiny
furry creatures will find themselves on
the end of that arrow for now unless you
cross that part
exactly exactly don't cross me she'll
kill you yes be warned yeah totally I'm
not joking do you want you look quite
scary when you say that yeah getting
into me rural Velvets a little bit too
much they need to love it yeah now and I
wanted to ask you who your favorite
characters are on the show so far any
video tour um my favorite coach is well
like I already said to them is one of my
favorite characters I think she's really
cool I genuinely just like all of the
women who dress like men I think it's
great
so like that I really love the strong
female characters and I think there can
only we can only have more of them so
they're like yeah I reckon they're the
best ones so then once I've been
enjoying most watching so far if you
could be any videos in the show who
would you be
oh wow that is a really difficult
question oh my god I don't know who
would you be oh my god no one ever asked
me yeah right now you know it's a really
like Easter yeah it's a difficult
question I'll have to think on that one
and get back to you we'll ask you that
next time you think about it well and
what's it meant to you being part of
Game of Thrones
it's been amazing to be part of Game of
Thrones because it's such a huge kind of
world and it's something which people
like across the world every so into and
like I just think that the way it's
plotted like it's so intricate and
amazing and like richly produced you
know it's it's amazing to be a part of
it to get to do all of these like get
like go out to Belfast to do all this
man things I never would have thought
I'd done like it's great and to be doing
that and be involved in a series playing
a pretty badass character it's great I'm
loving it and we'd like to say to the
fans out there who are watching this
interview ah if they're only fans
watching this interview I just like to
say thank you for watching the show and
I hopefully look forward to meeting one
of you or many of you sometime one of
these conventions
you